today on the matte wall show joe biden's
coronavirus advisor is on the record
saying that everyone is better off
dying at the age of 75. seems like a
rather serious conflict of interest
there also
five headlines including brave feminists
remaining silent as prosecutors drop
sexual assault charges against jacob
blake as part of a plea deal
and also the mayor of dc is the latest
democrat mayor to break her own
quarantine rules this is happening a lot
she's the latest one
apparently she gets to be an exception
she explained and in our daily
cancellation i must cancel
many states across our union for the
sins that they've committed this has
nothing to do with the election it's
just it's much more serious than that in
fact
um all of that is on the way but but
first
a message from lifelock you know current
events have
proven that now more than ever it's
critical to protect your online data
this could be challenging especially for
people who find it hard to work at home
you know i've been working at home not
now but i did that for a long time and
it's difficult to do
hotels are advertising daytime room
reservations for guests seeking quiet
distraction-free work environments but
according to the fbi
accessing sensitive information from
hotel wi-fi poses an increased security
risk over
home wi-fi networks because more people
of course have access to it hackers can
exploit
lacks hotel wi-fi security to steel work
and personal data
so it's important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting
your lives today all of our lives it's
one of the ways it's many other ways as
well every day we put our information at
risk on the internet
and you could miss certain identity
threats if you're just monitoring your
credit doing things like that
that's why it's great there's lifelock
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number being for sale
on the dark web and if they do detect
your information has potentially been
compromised
they're gonna send you an alert and
they're gonna let you know um
it's uh it's you know it's now is the
time now is probably
the best time for us to start thinking
about protecting our information we know
that we have to be prepared
um for for for whatever you know life
throws at us
and like i said i've i've done this
myself i've been at the
i've been at the hotel rooms you know
just last week i was doing it and uh you
know
it did occur to me then how vulnerable
we
potentially are look no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own so
join now save 25 off your first year
and you can do that by going to
lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off all right now
if joe biden ultimately does win the
presidency and we must stress
as always the if here but if he does
we're going to experience the
significant drawbacks of having the
anti-life party lead a pandemic response
of course we've already seen this at the
state level we know what that looks like
they sent covet patients into nursing
homes because they didn't value the
lives of the elderly
they shut down businesses destroyed
people's lives
livelihoods and lives because they
didn't care about the lives they
destroyed that way
either of course the people who
advocated these measures
they always claimed that they were the
pro-life ones right and we're the fake
pro-lifers because we objected to the
shutdowns
what they didn't understand or pretended
not to understand is that
being pro-life also means caring about
quality of life it's not just a matter
of preserving a person's mere
existence there is more to living than
simply
not dying all of that said it's
important to remember that
the quality of life phrase can also be
used by
advocates for the culture of death who
argue for
for example mercifully killing those who
they have decided
do not have quality of life or will not
have it should they be allowed to live
so we'll have more on that in just a
minute but that's that's the point is
that's not what i mean when i say
quality of life
the anti-life party though um they can't
discern
these distinctions we saw that as well
when the rioting hit and they let the
mobs run
wild burning and looting at will because
the human cost the human loss
didn't register in their minds all of
this becomes
more pronounced when you take it to a
national scale into the white house
which brings us to ezekiel emanuel okay
he's an oncologist
and a so-called bioethicist he's also
been appointed to be one of joe biden's
very crucial coronavirus advisors now
remember that coronavirus
disproportionately kills those who are
75 and older
which is why it caused so much
decimation when andrew cuomo knowingly
introduced it into nursing homes
75 and older that's the age range now
look at the article that ezekiel emanuel
wrote not all that long ago back in 2014
for the atlantic
his article says it's titled why i hope
to die
at 75 an argument that society and
families
and you will be better off if nature
takes its course swiftly and promptly
yes you will be better off not existing
if you've already existed for more than
75 years ezekiel ezekiel manuel
has drawn the line in the sand nobody
should exist
past this age and he's come up with the
age he has determined the point
when the lights have to be switched off
and the party has to end sorry guys
now personally i would say that god is
the one who comes up with that age and
it's different for everybody
but as we have seen throughout history
and especially in our culture today
if you don't accept that there is a god
you get to be one
and you get to be the one who comes up
with these sorts of rules
so here's some of what the article says
it says a simple truth that many of us
seem to resist
living too long is a loss it renders
many of us
if not disabled then faltering and
declining
a state that may not be worse than death
but is nonetheless deprived
it robs us of our creativity and ability
to contribute to work
society the world it transforms how
people experience us
relate to us and most important remember
us
we are no longer remembered as vibrant
and engaged but as feeble ineffectual
even pathetic
by the time i reached 75 i will have
lived a complete life i will have loved
and been loved my children will be grown
in the midst of their own rich lives i
will have seen my grandchildren born and
beginning their lives
i will have pursued my life's projects
and made whatever contributions
important or not
i am going to make and hopefully i will
not have too many
mental and physical limitations dying at
75
will not be a tragedy now if you're not
sufficiently horrified just yet
he later talks about what sort of
medical care
he thinks we should accept after the age
of 75. here's some of that he says
what about simple stuff flu shots are
out
certainly if they were if there were to
be a flu pandemic
a younger person who has yet to live a
complete life ought to get the vaccine
or
any anti-viral drugs a big challenge is
antibiotics for pneumonia or skin and
urine in urinary infections
antibiotics are cheap and largely
effective and carry infections
it's really hard for us to say no indeed
even people who are
sure they don't want life extending
treatments find it hard to refuse
antibiotics
but as oslo reminds us unlike the decays
associated with chronic conditions
death from these infections is quick and
relatively painless
so no to antibiotics all right
so to recap joe biden's chronovirus
advisor
does not think life is worth living at
75 after 75
doesn't see the doesn't see the death of
someone 75 or over to be tragic
doesn't think that uh people that age
should be accepting flu shots or even
antibiotics
at least he doesn't think he should
accept them after 75 though i'm sure his
opinion will likely change on that score
once he is 75 if he has according to him
the misfortune of making it that far
now call me crazy but i think there
might be a conflict of interest here
the guy advising the president on how to
deal with a disease that mostly kills
the elderly
doesn't actually think it's a problem if
the elderly are killed
in fact he sees it as a net positive for
society and even for the person who dies
and keep in mind that the president
himself if the president becomes
is joe biden then the president himself
will be over the age of 75.
so that has to be awkward to be advised
by someone
who thinks you should be dead though in
fairness it seems like trump ran into
that problem a lot as well
perhaps a built-in hazard of the
presidency i don't know even so
there are two important points to be
made here number one
this man is a bioethicist and you'll
notice how bioethicists
medical ethicists ethicists in general
these days
are a bit hamstrung by the fact that
they don't see human life as inherently
meaningful or valuable
ethics is all about developing a moral
system or a code to govern our behavior
and our interactions with
each other and the world but the most
fundamental principle that ought to
govern our behavior towards others is
our recognition
of their inherent value and their human
dignity
if you have no such recognition your
ethics will be perverse and often you
will arrive at ethical conclusions
that are exactly the opposite of correct
so you probably wouldn't want a suicidal
nihilist as your skydiving instructor
so you should want them as our we
shouldn't want them as our professional
ethicists either
those skydiving instructors are quite a
bit more crucial to society than
professional ethicists anyway
we could probably do without
professional ethicists in general
especially ones that think our
grandmother should be dead
second point is that again the democrat
party is the party of death this is the
party that after all has facilitated
funded supported cheered on
the mass slaughter of 60 million infants
calling them the party of death is not
hyperbole they have earned that label
they have earned it with the blood of
many dead children
and the fact is that they don't see the
destruction of life as objectively wrong
or immoral they object
only when such objections are
politically useful so they weep
for example over somebody like george
floyd a convicted violent criminal
but blood is shed by the bucketful every
day in the cities they manage
the cities they ostensibly control they
don't seem terribly distressed by it
now we're threatened with the
possibility of these people taking over
our
pandemic response and we're already
seeing what direction that will go
and it's not good to put it lightly
all right let's get to our five
[Music]
headlines
you know uh we don't know what's gonna
happen in the future if we've learned
nothing in 2020 we've learned that
there's a lot that happened in 2020 that
i don't think anyone predicted uh i
if you did predict it then i hope you
won a lot of money on all the bets you
must have
put down but you can't most people most
people unless you're unless you uh you
know can see it to the future we don't
know that's why you need to be prepared
and now is a a better time than any to
be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options and that's
where ready wise comes in readywise has
many options like emergency meals
they've got freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient
on-the-go nutrition they've also got
these new adventure meals which i've
tried
if you're hiking or camping or like
outdoor activities
then you want to grab some of those um a
lot better than the typical like energy
bars that you pick up
at at the drugstore ready wise makes
being prepared simple and affordable you
can order online
have nutritious meals shipped directly
to your doorstep
but here's something to keep in mind
with the increased demand supplies are
limited and some items may be currently
out of stock what that means is act now
go now to the website get your
ready-wise meals when government
resources are strained it can be days if
not weeks before fresh fruit is
available
don't put yourself in a situation when
you need food during an emergency
you know by that time it might be too
late prepared today
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you can order online you
can have nutritious meals
shipped directly to your doorstep when
preparing our meals
all you need is uh four cups of water
water doesn't even need to be hot okay
it's all you need to have is just
running water
you simply pour the food into water stir
and cover after about 15 minutes the
meal is ready
some meals can even be prepared directly
in the pouch eliminating the need for
additional supplies
uh and so it's just it's really easy to
do and also the food tastes good
and but but listen you you have to be
prepared now once the emergency happens
it's too late and then you're gonna be
saying oh i wish we had
done this i wish we'd gotten prepared
it's too late then so go now
and i'll make it easy for you this week
my listeners can get free shipping at
readywise.com
when entering walsh at checkout or you
can call 855-475-3089
ready wise has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
here
taking the initiative get yourself and
your family prepared today
that's ready wise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot
com promo code walsh
to get free shipping today all right
um number one here the daily wire
reports kenosha
prosecutors have dropped the sex assault
charges against jacob blake
following a plea agreement um blake
pleaded guilty now jacob blake of course
he was the uh
he's the the man in kenosha who was
shot by police officers as he was uh as
police officers were called to the scene
he was allegedly
harassing um a woman who also had
accused him of
of raping her and he had a knife he
assaulted the cops he tried to get into
a car
not his car he tried to get into the
woman's car uh
with his kids in there they tried to
stop him they told him to stop he
reached into the car and then they shot
so that was the recap on that
but he had these sex assault charges uh
again the woman
whose house he was at had accused him of
sexual assault
now prosecutors are dropping those
charges
as part of a plea agreement right blake
pleaded guilty to two counts of
disorderly conduct in order to
get the third degree sexual assault
charge dropped
blake told judge brian schroeder
honestly your honor though i plead
guilty to this i don't consider myself
to be guilty i pretty much took this
opportunity to get to see my children
quicker
blake also said he did not sexually
assault the woman making the allegations
against him blake's attorney
said dropping the charge meant
prosecutors were acknowledging that
ultimately the state could not prove it
in court
uh walworth county district attorney
zeke weidenfeld
told the outlet that the sexual assault
charge was dropped in part because the
accuser refused to cooperate with
prosecution
yeah well of course she refused to
cooperate
and the fact that they didn't that you
know they didn't have evidence to prove
it in court
does not at all mean it didn't happen
these are very we have to keep
remember this these are extremely
credible charges against jacob leg
the reason why they're extremely
credible is because
his accuser called police the morning
that this
incident happened she said that jacob
blake broke into her window
at like 6 a.m on like a sunday morning
and walked into a room where she was
sleeping and sexually assaulted her
and then stole her keys her car in a
credit card and left
she she called 9-1-1 and she was
trembling and crying she was still in
her you know in her in her nightgown
and they came and they saw her there
crying and and
obviously traumatized um
i would call that an extremely credible
accusation this is this isn't one of
those accusations somebody comes out of
the woodwork
woodwork you know 30 years later this is
at the moment calling police this is
what happened to me
uh she's not cooperating okay of course
she's not cooperating
her alleged abuser who by the way she
says
has been abusing her for years not just
that one time
for years she said um and he's been
lionized
canonized by the media by the democrat
party
the potential new president of the
united states
went and met with jacob blake's family
and jacob blake himself
and was singing his praises afterwards
so all of the most powerful people
matt put yourself in this woman's
position
uh assuming that her allegations are
true which i absolutely believe her
believe all women no we don't believe
all women i believe this woman because
the allegations are credible
put yourself in her position you are
viciously assaulted by this man
and now and and then a few months later
he comes steals your keys
you're trying to protect him from you
know your kids uh
gets himself shot in the after
assaulting police
and now all the most powerful voices in
society are coming to his defense and
saying he's a great guy
he's a great father even
what is she supposed to do she comes out
and
tries to get this guy locked away
um she's gonna be worried for her own
safety she's gonna be worried about uh
about you know being dragged through the
mud so you you you can definitely see
where she's coming from there
but where are the feminists on this
this this is something where you know
you would think feminists would come out
and come to this woman's
defense i haven't heard anything
and we have seen this whether it's with
jacob blake george floyd
you know there have been at least three
or four cases just the last few months
of blm making martyrs and heroes and and
canonizing
uh men who have abused women
in horrible ways and those women are
silenced
nobody talks about them nobody cares
about them feminists not coming to
their defense because feminists are of
course disingenuous phonies
in almost every single case
number two governor cuomo speaking of
disingenuous phonies was on with george
stephanopoulos
who by the way stephanopoulos is
apparently lobbying to be alex trebek's
replacement that's another update here
i mean he's not lobbying cuomo i don't
think andrew cuomo makes that decision
but
he's lobbying to get on jeopardy be the
new replacement for for jeopardy talk
about a talk about a step down in
quality i mean
you go from the most likable guy in
america
to one of the most insufferable goobers
in america
that is that's a very steep drop in
quality
losing trebek and ending up with this
guy it's like remaking a john wayne
movie
and casting like i don't know
kate mckinnon in his role or something
which i don't want to give hollywood
ideas that sounds like something they
would actually do
anyway here's uh here's cuomo talking to
george stephanopoulos
and the potential of a vaccine coming
out soon
he doesn't seem very happy about it
oddly enough here he is
we were talking yesterday about the
importance of vaccine distribution in
the next
two months what do you make of this news
uh well
it's it's good news bad news george the
good news is
uh the pfizer tests look good and we'll
have a vaccine
shortly the bad news is that it's about
two months before
joe biden takes over and that means this
administration is going to be
implementing a vaccine
plan you have two months and we can't
let this vaccination plan go
forward the way the trump administration
is designing it
because biden can't undo it two months
later we'll be in the midst of it
and i'm going i've been talking to
governors across the nation about that
uh how can we shape the trump
administration vaccine plan to fix it
or stop it uh before it does damage yeah
the only thing
may be surprising about any of this is
just how
utterly transparent these people are
being
andrew cuomo is not even trying to hide
it he does not want
donald trump getting credit for this
vaccine he does not want this coming out
on on trump's watch doesn't want it
seems to me he would rather have people
die just so trump doesn't get the credit
utterly transparent and speaking of
being transparent uh mark seagraves of
nbc 4 in washington reports quote dc
mayor bowser and
her staff attended joe biden's victory
speech in wilmington
on saturday delaware is on the mayor's
list of high-risk states which would
require quarantine after returning
bowser's staff says the trip was
essential travel
exempted under mayor's order essential
travel
going to a victory speech at another
state
so you can you know shake hands and hug
and celebrate
that's essential travel now
but mayor bowser just joins a long list
of democrat mayors and they have really
all been democrats
democrat mayors disregarding their own
rules and saying i don't know i get to
i get to be an exception to this i
forgot to tell you
just making up the rules as they go
along
democrats with with the chronovirus
regulations
they remind me a lot of my own kids
in maybe more ways than one but they
remind me of my own children or
they remind me of children in general
but my own kids you know
i play a game with them and they make up
rules as they go
very conveniently like i'm playing tag
with my kids
and they just decide that whatever tree
they're standing next to oh this is base
i'm safe here
that's what the democrats are doing with
the chronovirus restrictions they they
can say oh no
you're not supposed to travel but if
you're going to a victory speech for joe
biden then um
did we not put that in the rules i meant
to are we meant to put in the rules
that's an exception this is something
that people have
liberals have have never understood or
at least have acted like they don't
understand
one of the the primary objections to the
coronavirus
restrictions it's it's not just
that they're onerous though that they
are and that is an objection
but what makes it worse what makes it
untenable
and intolerable and especially
tyrannical
is that they are arbitrary and that they
are not
consistently applied to everyone that is
the real problem
if these restrictions were put in place
and everybody was expected to follow
them
and no exceptions were made and we're
not making exceptions for blm
rioters and people who are dancing the
streets because of uh
joe biden supposedly has won the
presidency now we're not making
exceptions so that the mayor of chicago
can go and get her
her hair done or that nancy pelosi can
and we're not making exceptions for bill
de blasio in new york
everybody follows it i would still
object
but it wouldn't be nearly as oppressive
then we would be objecting on the
grounds that this is just a bad strategy
uh it's you know it's not the right way
to approach this i mean we would still
be strenuously objecting
but what what what makes it infuriating
and what makes it oppressive is the
arbitrariness of it
and the double standards triple
standards quadruple standards the
standards keep changing by the
by the second all right number four if
you want to see what real courage looks
like
here it is look at this footage here blm
protesters marching
in michigan um i don't know if these are
protesters now or
revelers if they're celebrating i don't
know but they're they're marching
this was on i think saturday and this is
what you see now you see these diners
at a restaurant preemptively giving the
black power fist
so they don't get yelled at uh and then
and then there's this old this this old
guy here who's i don't know what he's
doing he's raising the roof
that's not the black power symbol he's
he's raising the roof
okay a little bit behind the times with
his with his gestures
that's all right um oh no this is this
isn't courage i'm sorry i use the wrong
word this is the exact opposite of
courage
also notice how almost all these people
are white here
all the people sitting at the tables
almost everyone in the crowd all bunch
of white people
virtue signaling by giving the black
power symbol to each other
look i understand you don't want a a mob
descending on you when you're trying to
eat your brunch
or whatever you're eating but at a
certain point you have to have a little
bit of courage grow a little bit of a
spine
number five checking in now with the
great journalistic publication jezebel
uh my producer sent me this blame him
not me apparently the new adaptation of
the witches
is facing backlash because the villain
has a disability
and that's that's uh that's a problem
the article says warner brothers has
apologized after receiving criticism
over their depiction of anne hathaway's
grand witch character
in their new adaptation of uh rual
doll's
book the witches yes it is pronounced
ruel by the way not roll
in the movie hathaway's character is
which i just learned yesterday i'm not
gonna pretend like i knew it before
in the movie hathaway's character is
missing fingers making it appear as
though she has the limb difference
ectrodactyly commonly known as split
hand
this falls into a harmful pattern of
giving villainous characters physical
disabilities perpetuating the oppressive
idea
that people with disabilities are scary
or somehow less moral than people
without disabilities
the vice president of communications at
respect ability an organization that
advocates for people with disabilities
also called out the film's decision to
associate disability with evil
characters
in this case even choosing to add a limb
difference that was not a part of doll's
original story
unfortunately this representation in the
witches teaches kids that limb
differences are hideous or something to
be afraid of
what type of message does this send to
children with limb differences
according to a spokesperson of for
warner brothers the studio was deeply
saddened that their depiction of the
characters in the witches might have
upset people with disabilities
but then listen to their statement they
said in adapting the original story
we worked with designers and artists to
come up with a new interpretation of the
cat-like claws that are described in the
book
it was never the intention for viewers
to feel that the fantastical non-human
creatures
were meant to represent them is it just
me or warner brothers throwing a little
bit of shade here as the kids would say
maybe it's wishful thinking or
projection but i'm picking up on some
serious
sarcasm in their in their statement
which i like
at any rate if this is offensive then
the penguin
in batman must be really traumatic
though you never know with that one
whether the penguin is offensive on this
basis
or maybe because he's appropriating from
avian culture
who really knows but i am glad we're
having this conversation because i've
always been disturbed by
the villains who wear glasses as a
member of the visually impaired
community
vic vic victim as a member of that
community and also as a member of
the facial hair community i'm extremely
distressed
by villains who can wear glasses have
facial hair a lot of times
um for example look at this jim carrey's
portrayal of dr robotnik
in the recent uh sonic the hedgehog film
great film by any other measure
but you can see there he's got glasses
and he's got a mustache
and when i see this it's almost as if
the makers of the film
are trying to give the impression that
anyone with glasses and facial hair is
probably hatching a dastardly plot
to kill a magical hedgehog this is a
stereotype that i have carried with me
for years every time i walk down the
street people are shouting like hey
catch any hedgehogs today you loser ha
and they high-five each other
i run away crying it happens every day
so i'm glad that jezebel is calling
attention to this issue it is uh very
important
all right um we're going to get to our
daily cancellation
in just a second but first
i want to tell you about wondering you
know
i'm a parent of four kids if you're a
parent you know we'll do anything to
protect
our kids imagine you're a parent
nervously pacing around your injured
child's hospital room
a doctor begins asking you questions um
you know about how your kid got hurt you
begin to realize
that they're asking about your
involvement in the accident
where were you when you fell how did he
actually fall
and then you slowly start to see that
they think that you hurt your child
intentionally this is this is something
a lot of parents have
been through i mean you're going to have
medical emergencies with your kids it
just it happens
wondering nbc news present do not
do no harm that is the terrifying true
story of a family torn apart by the
system that was supposed to protect them
investigative reporter mike hixenbeau
chronicles
what happens to the bright family when
their three kids are
ripped away from them and the shocking
moments that came after that
with exclusive audio captured as the
events unfolded do no harm
takes you inside the most harrowing
moments of the bright families
fight to protect their children this is
this is a just a story that is
harrowing if you're a parent and
potentially relatable
but also something that you need to
listen to subscribe to do no harm on
apple podcast you can join
laundry plus in the wondering app to
listen uh one week early and you can
also listen ad free again that's do no
harm apple podcast
join wonder plus and listen one week
early
all right uh one other thing to mention
before we get to our daily cancellation
gotta
hit a couple notes here if you look at
the election coverage it's obvious
of course the media has an agenda and
they aren't afraid to push it
we've kept you in the loop every step of
the way we've tried to there's a lot
going on we're trying to
try to keep you up to date on it and
it's still too soon to tell who will win
so you can join daily wire right now get
25
off with code election so you can keep
up with us on all the unfolding twists
and turns
there's a lot more that's going to
happen in the next couple of months and
you don't want to have to rely on the
media the mass media
to tell you about it not only that we
have big plans for these next four years
regardless of who the president turns
out to be we've announced that candace
owens new york times bestselling author
founder of the blexit foundation will be
launching a brand new show with us early
next year in nashville which is very
exciting
as well as writing content for us over
at dailywire.com we'll also be launching
an entertainment channel a new
investigative
journalism team building partnerships
with like-minded
content creators like prageru whose
entire show library by the way is
available to
dailywire.com by the end of the year to
be available to you again that's 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today
because if there's one thing 2020 has
taught us it's that anything
can happen all right let's get to our
daily cancellation
well today for our daily cancellation
it's going to be a bloodbath i have to
cancel a whole host of states
and it's got nothing to do with the
election this is all about
side dishes graham elliott famous tv
chef posted this graphic you can see
here the most
popular thanksgiving dishes side dishes
by state that's the graphic
now i don't know where he got this
information i'm going to assume it's
correct because i read it on the
internet i did try to cross-reference it
and i found the same chart
on the website delish.com and i figured
that's probably more fact-checking than
this subject really warrants so i'll
leave it at that
now as you can see the map reveals uh i
think a deep sickness
and confusion and moral rot in our
culture
many of these states apparently do not
know how to properly assemble a
thanksgiving plate
some of the things here that are
revealed are frankly shocking to me
so let's start with the positive all
right i take no issue with green bean
casserole as a favorite side which means
texas
texas new mexico arizona uh idaho
some others they're all safe fine mashed
potatoes of course are overrated but
they are a staple of any self-respecting
thanksgiving ensemble so
california nevada uh most of the states
up there on the on the canadian border
safe from cancellation at least today
indiana has deviled eggs as their side
dish of of choice which
is controversial because deviled eggs
are more appropriate at easter dinner
than thanksgiving
however i will allow it because i am
merciful and besides indiana doesn't
have much else going on food wise or in
any other respect the poor things so
i won't be too hard on them no offense
if you live in indiana
my new home tennessee has sweet potato
casserole as a favorite side dish that's
perfectly fine answer
then if you go up into the northeast
into new england stuffing is the
favorite side dish by the way this is
the correct answer homemade stuffing
with gravy is objectively the most
important
thanksgiving side dish notice i said
most important there's a nuance here
i didn't say it's the best i said it's
the most important in that
your thanksgiving plate simply makes no
sense it's absurd if it doesn't have
stuffing on it
somebody who passes over the stuffing at
thanksgiving has immediately revealed
themselves to be a degenerate and a
freak
and i will tell them that to their face
and i have and many thanksgiving dinners
have gotten off to an awkward start
because of it now
things go off the rails though at this
point first we've got all these states
missouri oklahoma others that have rolls
as their most popular side dish rolls
that's not a side dish you might as well
say napkins are your favorite side dish
a roll is not a proper side
then look at maine of course these
weirdos have salad
salad i remain convinced that nobody
actually likes salad eating a salad is a
chore
it's something you do to punish yourself
it's atonement
or else it's done in a desperate attempt
to virtue signal
that's why people when they eat salad
they're always like oh look at me with
my salad
aren't you impressed i mean nobody's
ever actually said that out loud when
they eat salad as far as i know but
they're thinking it i can tell
salad's the kind of thing that you add
to your
spread because you can't think of
anything else because you lack culinary
vision
and then nobody eats it and you're left
with 30 pounds of rabbit food that you
have to go donate to a petting zoo
have you ever in your entire life seen a
thanksgiving dinner run out of salad
have you ever heard someone say can you
pass the salad and then someone else
says oh sorry it's gone
you hear that with green bean casserole
you hear with stuffing cranberry sauce
yams hell even roasted vegetables
are gonna are you're gonna run out of
those eventually even even the stupid
useless rolls get eaten
never the salad you never hear what that
was there's always salad left over
because nobody gives a damn about it
in fact the salad is always getting
pushed on you at the end there's always
sales pitches being given for the salad
you ask for another turkey leg and
somebody goes
oh those are gone but do you want salad
no i don't want salad you're damned
lunatic
and then you've got organ over there
with biscuits listen
i'm a big biscuit fan but biscuits don't
belong on thanksgiving that's very
strange
and half of the eastern seaboard from
maryland and delaware on down through
the carolinas and georgia
all claiming mac and cheese macaroni and
cheese as their favorite thanksgiving
side
i want to be clear about this and you're
not going to like it mac and cheese is
not a thanksgiving side for adults it's
fine for kids
once you grow out of the phase where
you're drinking out of juice boxes and
eating fruity pebbles for breakfast
you need to be done with mac and cheese
don't tell me your grandmother has a
great recipe for it there are no great
recipes for mac and cheese
mac and cheese is a pasta dish for
people who haven't discovered
that real pasta exists it tops out
like a c-plus b-minus dish i'm sorry
you've fallen for your grandmother's
propaganda
and fake news and i'm sorry you had to
hear it from me
i don't make the rules i discern them
through deep meditation and oneness with
the universe
and this is simply the truth so the
southern half of the east coast states
plus maine missouri oklahoma all
canceled
and alabama alabama has dressing as its
favorite side
dressing as a side what are you doing in
alabama guzzling ranch right out of the
bottle
how is that a side dish alabama is
cancelled
half the states in the union are
canceled and they are all banned from
having thanksgiving dinners
it will not be allowed for their own
good
and mine and uh on that serious note we
are going to
leave it there for today thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
journals whale that trump will not
concede
fraud turns up in swing states and aoc
threatens to leave
politics check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]
you